and for the cardinals it's going to be
austin gomberg getting the ball in this
one
and gomber no stranger to starting games
had 11 starts last year
no score top of the first half still at
first
and the batter javier baez two and two
on javier baez out of puerto rico
the pitch strike three called right down
the middle at the knees
what a wild inning for gomber walking
half
got the pitch count up there but he
struck out too it's a zero
that it is we go to the bottom of the
first the cardinals are coming to bat
as the home team on the north side of
chicago the
cubs again are the visiting team they go
with colin reyes making his second start
he's been used mostly out of the bullpen
he's 1-0 with a 3.75 er8 goldschmidt at
first base for
brad miller nico horner remains on the
left side the pitch swing and a missed
strike three a vanishing slider
jose looking for his first hit in a cub
uniform
the pitch to jose a swing and a hot shot
backhanded on one hop by the young he
throws in time for the out
bottom of the second paul de young leads
off against colin ray
nothing nothing the pitch is swung on
and there's a drive
hit deep left field and it is gone a
home run
up into the bleachers paul de young with
his third home run of the year and the
cardinals are on the boarding game too
now what is tyler o'neill going to do
from the stretch here's the pitch
and there's a swing and a high fly ball
that's it to deep right field it might
go
it's a goner an opposite field home run
for tyler o'neal
his first home run since the 15th of
august
and o'neill hits his fourth of the year
three-nothing
cardinals in the second ryan helsley
a right-hander will face javier baez
bias represents the tying run third
inning two outs
two on and a 2-2 delivery
from helsley here it comes curveball is
popped up
and that is going to be shallow left
field backing up is deung he calls off
the left fielder o'neal and makes the
play over his shoulder baez and the cubs
are retired good work ryan helsley
that sends us to the bottom of the third
inning cardinals three cubs nothing
so runners at the corners and brad
miller
hit the other way in a base hit
tommy edmond will score and it's
four-nothing miller drives in edmond
and the cardinals lead four-nothing and
they are blistering the baseball
in the last couple of innings and that
brings in lane thomas
who walked had a good at-bat in fact and
walked in front of the tyler o'neill
home run
thomas hits the ground ball to shore
baez charges flips to kepnes there's one
over to first call it two a double play
it'll bring up victor caratini with the
cubs
down four here in the fourth but hellsly
has the big time fastball and will he
throw it here
two and two to carratini
a long look long look and the pitch two
two pitches grounded to the right side
that's four six three and a double play
it'll bring up harrison bader who flat
out to left
in the second he's over one infield in
for bader
and he hits that ball down the right
field line that's carrying out to
jason hayward who runs it down on the
warning track but another good at that
sacrifice fly rbi harrison bader
and it's five nothing cardinal one down
and david bodie at the plate cubs trail
five-nothing with men at first and third
we are in the fifth inning it's a seven
inning game
runners lead at first and third here's
the ground ball right side backhanded by
goldschmidt he'll make the play
unassisted at first as a run scores
he wanted to throw to second couldn't
get the ball out of the glove
horner comes in to score but that is the
second out in the inning
three unassisted bodhi retired give
voting an rbi
and on the play kittness goes to second
base
so bodhi will get an rbi it's five to
one
right-hander john gant now pitching for
saint louis javier baez at the plate
schwarber after the walk is at first
very interesting how mike schilt decides
to go with the
last few innings of this game maybe a
little bit ahead of where he wanted to
be
with the trouble that has happened in
this inning gant
is in and a swing and a miss he strikes
out baez who chased the ball in the dirt
again
and that was the change-up of gant he
gets his man
that sends us to the bottom of the fifth
inning good work for john gant
five 5-1 cody drove in the cubs only run
with a fifth inning ground out
andrew miller with a 3-2 pitch air for
david body the cubs are down to their
last strike the pitch
is swung on and it is popped up short
right field
out goes wong he calls off thomas wong
makes the catch
it was a tough play but he was able to
backhand it
he's looking to the sky saying woo glad
i caught that one and that's a red bird
winner